hi everyone welcome to another live
stream if you don't know me my name is
Gwen and I run another youtube channel
called Faraday Academy where I do
programming tutorials and live streams
mostly mostly Python and view Jas
JavaScript topics so today is a
continuation of building the free code
camp projects live in View Jas so last
week I did the markdown previewer and
this week I'm gonna go to the drum
machine let me just zoom in here so
these should be linked in the
description below and you can go to my
github which is that Gwen F and this is
called free code camp projects view and
then I have each project in its own
folder with a readme yeah so for today
I'm gonna be starting a view app with
the view CLI using Inc line which is a
view UI framework for styling and design
components that kind of thing and this
is basically the mock-up for the drum
machine now I did find sounds for this
already just because I didn't want to be
scrounging for sounds here so I came up
with these sounds that I edited myself
but they're in the wrong format I won't
play in the browser for some reason so I
ended up getting some random sounds in
this clip jas file here so they won't
sound exactly like a drum so it's gonna
be more like a sound machine than a drum
machine yeah
that's a horse so if any one has better
sounds let me know but these were the
easiest they're just mp3 files from
sound Bible which sound Bible has all
these free sounds sometimes you have to
give attribution and sometimes there
public domain so it depends which sound
just one second I'm going to pull up the
chat real quick
and okay good
let me see who's here if you're here go
ahead and say hi and feel free to give
me comments or recommendations as I'm
going along with the live stream this
will be interesting because I generally
don't work with sound in the browser
when building applications but there's
also a couple other applications I want
to build with sound in the future like a
music app so hopefully hey tech stats
hey Sasi
yeah thanks for joining me feel free to
chime in as I'm programming today
alright so yeah there's a couple other
sound apps I want to build in the future
so this should be a good project - I
guess lean on later so first thing let
me start here so first thing I need to
create a view app so I already have the
view CLI installed so I'm gonna do view
create and let's call this drum machine
I guess it's in a folder called drum
machine so maybe I'll just call this
drum app alright and it should give me
my options yeah so let's see do I want
anything let me just go into manual do a
lot progressive web app support that's
easy to add later
I don't need routing it's just gonna be
one page this time view X don't think so
do I want sass I think I'll be okay
without sass let me put it in just in
case and I'm not gonna do testing so
I'll use regular dart sass
yes lint I'm gonna do just the basic is
lint
to go better and livestreams when it's
not giving the errors all the time went
on save yeah that's good and then I want
dedicated config files save the preset
no all right so that's installing what's
the difference between sass and dart
sass they're both implementations of
sass I think dart sass is the most
popular and I want to say it's the
fastest but I'm not sure anymore I think
it's just what most people use like
there was I guess Ruby sass and a couple
other projects sass built in different
ways but it's the same implementation
the only I guess the only two different
types of sass are indented syntax and
the S CSS style and those and you can
use either of those styles with any of
the implementations
all right
should be done in a minute
okay
it's installing
bookin generators from the plugins that
I installed which is just Sasso I guess
I did babble to which is just one of the
default ones I just launched if you're
interested in view CLI plugins I just
created a video on my channel Faraday
Academy where I show how to create
plugins and kind of how they work under
the hood it was pretty interesting for
me to learn about so maybe you'd enjoy
it too alright so now let's see now I
have oh wow so drum machine I thought I
was inside of drum machine already so
drum app I'm gonna move drum app inside
of the drum machine folder now so let's
see because all the other apps are
inside of their their folders for that
app so move drum machine to the move
drum app to drum machine okay so now
yeah I only have the three folders one
for each project and now if I CD into
drum machine cool I see drum app so let
me open this in the code editor then go
in here and then I'll also go ahead and
CD into drum app and then I'm gonna
start my view server so NPM run serve
all right and that always takes a minute
to build and let me put my browser in
the middle all right so now that's
building and actually first I'm going to
install the inclined library and
probably the best way to do that is
through the CLI install so I'll just add
this real quick so then I'm gonna have
to rerun uncommitted changes yeah that's
fine okay so that should only take a
second to install and set it up for me
what's nice about using the view CLI
plugins is that they set up all the
configuration so I can just start using
the components without setting anything
else up okay so first thing I'm gonna do
is set up the grid so let me go to the
drum machine mock-up so it's a pretty
simple mock-up I just want basically
this box to be centered and then I want
a panel on top that I guess has some
controls like you can turn it off and on
there's some volume in the name of the
sound that's being played which I just
gave them names in objects so that have
a name and then each one of these panels
or buttons or whatever they're gonna be
when you click on it it'll make that
sound okay excessively invoked okay so
now inclined is installed I don't think
I need to install anything else right
now so I'm just going to do NPM run
serve to start the development server
and then I'll be able to see my app
localhost 8080
okay and in my source directory I want
these clips this clips that Jas file so
I'm just gonna drag that in here let's
see yeah
I'll just put it in the root for now all
right
let me see and my server is not running
let's see
module build failed compound selectors
may no longer be extended hmm okay so
this is an inclined problem I already
have an error but where is this coming
from it's coming from the actual
inclined components so in the node
modules I don't know if there's anything
I can do about it except maybe downgrade
my version of inclined balsamiq so let
me see balsamic balsamic mock ups is I
think it's a super easy tool for
developers people who aren't
professional designers to just quickly
make mock ups they have an online
version now but I have the desktop app
because I like it a little bit better
but they both work I think the online
ones a subscription model okay so root
stylesheet
consider extend to it yeah so this is a
problem inside of the incline library
let me go to their github page and look
at their issues and see what people are
doing
I'm sure someone else has had that issue
because that's literally the first thing
I did when I set up the app mmm I wonder
let's see yeah let me copy this
component selectors may no longer be
extended okay so this is a recent issue
yeah it seems like it's the same thing
that I'm having this shouldn't be
happening on a clean installation which
version of nodes ass okay so what I
might do actually is all right so let me
see
read me Sora's public okay let me see
said setting up inclined importing
inclined components registering them so
what I might do is I could just
uninstall inclined and then get rid of
the plug-in and then manually add it
because what might be causing the error
is let's see let me go back to getting
started is that I gave it this
customizable flag oh let's see and it's
dependencies have been added to your
package.json node sass and sass loader
and let me just check the versions of
those real quick
let's see sass loader and notes ass ok
and then yeah I have inclined and of
course the plug-in that installed
inclined
so it's a SAS problem okay so I wonder
if I restart all of this and I'm gonna
try this out again later to see if I
should open a bug or a new issue with
this because I literally didn't do
anything after I set this app up so it
shouldn't be giving me an error already
okay so if
shaking let me look at the getting
started
I wonder if I just do this instead if
I'm not importing certain components are
passing in any options what that's gonna
do it's rebuilding nope it's still doing
it so yeah it's a SAS problem so I
wonder if I should be using ink line I
just used this in the last project and
it worked totally fine so alright so I
guess I'm gonna be using a different
framework let me try
view bootstrap that should work and we
can start all over again
read this solution in a github issue you
mean on inclined I think I went I didn't
see any of the issues that had to do
with mine it was just that one closed
issue where there was no solution oh if
you tried to post a link
I don't think free code camp is letting
you post a link so I can't see it can
you just top give me the issue number
and okay and point notes ass from the
web pack like this con sus equals
required notes ass let me see let me
look at the issue
customizing not working okay let me see
his issue 170
oh this is a next though getting a
compile error module whoops
module built field bug report okay yeah
this is what I have okay
yeah this is the same issue though so I
don't know which one it's which issue
unless you give me an issue number I had
to remove sass default darts ass to
point at node sass
let's see transpiling dependencies I
could point it I don't know do I want to
do this I kind of want to start just
building the drum app I think for this I
can change it later but I think right
now I'm just gonna use bootstrap view
until I figure out what's wrong with ink
line and I don't believe I believe this
is just an NPM install let's see yeah so
it's it's not recommending me to you are
using okay so I have to install
bootstrap for you and bootstrap okay
icons plug-in alright so let me just
install this real quick and this will
just I just need a basic grid system and
some styling that's it
okay that's installing so there's no
plug in I just have to set it up in my
view file in my main view file where I
render from so main j/s and I'll put it
in here okay and then I guess I'll just
get rid of these and I could uninstall
inclined from here and it's all inclined
and the plug-in okay cool that installed
just fine so I'm going to do an NPM on
install the plug-in and let's see
incline
views imported twice now I might have
done that yeah okay thank you and
actually change the order of those
imports all right
and now
okay so import bootstrap view and then
just few dot use okay let me do
bootstrap for you and then if I want
icons later I'll do that
okay and now I'll do em p.m. run serve
and I think so Inc lines of pretty
lightweight libraries so I don't think
it gave me extra set up like some of the
larger UI libraries did you know I don't
see its own folder or anything here so I
think I got rid of it yeah it doesn't
even change the setup in the app dot
view file okay icons plug-in is defined
but never used yeah alright so I'll just
add it okay so that built okay cool it's
working now and I guess I'll just be
using the view bootstrap system
okay so components actually I think grid
yeah layout and grid system so it's
basically all prefixed from be container
be row and just by I think this gives me
all the components like I don't have to
individually import and register
components because I just registered the
whole library so let me try out I'll
just start programming
in my main file my main app dot view
file and then I'm gonna break up
components as I need them break things
up into components let me get rid of all
this styling - okay so first thing I'm
gonna do is a V container to start off
my grid system and then a weight
it's B I'm getting all these libraries
confused
so for bootstrap it's b and b ok and
then it will be B row inside and then B
column I think it's just call yeah be
call okay and then here is where I can
put it in the middle of the page so let
me put something in here first just some
text okay drum and now from here I can
give it the regular classes so or maybe
they're props here let me look in
columns yeah so I'll pass it in as a
prop instead of as a class so I'll do
column 4 so this will just be for all
screen sizes so 6 6 columns wide and
then how do I do opposite ok offset
equals so I think I can just do offset
equals 3
all right so that didn't work so first
let me see if there's an error here type
checked for prop call expected boolean
got string with value of six oh I think
it's calls isn't it I think it is calls
let me see yeah
calls so here calls
okay so that didn't give me an error but
it's still let me just see I inspect
this let me inspect the text okay
so row container class
of column six and wonder why they have
examples they don't really have how they
do okay let's see yeah this one says
calls eight so I should be able to do
that let's see I have B column so be
call B call and then calls of six and
then oh my offset is wrong yeah thank
you
that's okay
it's still not working so let's see
offset
why wouldn't offset be working does I
have an example with offset they do have
[Music]
auto so I think that centers it and
alignment
I guess that's flexbox see you can use
flexbox
let's see alright
so offset let me just try to do instead
of just general calls let me try to do a
small and then I can do offset - small
see if that works
mm-hmm that's weird we call medium
offset medium I'm closing the column all
right so let me put content in here and
see if I just if something else is going
to change it I guess cuz that's weird
yeah I'm doing it exactly like the
examples say let me even copy-paste the
example and let me do another row so all
right oh wait I wanted to put a row in
here so B row and then
maybe the CSS is not being loaded
correctly yeah that's true because it's
not working at all does it see because I
didn't think it said I thought let's see
oh it does say to add imports so add
import bootstrap view okay so let me put
this in the main J's file and that
should fix it ah okay alright that was a
lot of time spent on that thanks for the
help
okay let me get rid of that extra row
there okay
and yeah uh yeah I guess I'm like I'm so
used to setting it up setting up
component libraries just by using a
plugin so I do view add and then it sets
it up for me so I forgot I can't believe
I forgot to check for the CSS all right
so now finally I have the drum machine
so this is actually gonna be two cards
so the top card and the bottom card with
the sound button loops with the sound
buttons or whatever these are inside so
let me look for cards here
okay cards so just a basic card and then
I guess I can nest inside the cards with
text or just put components directly
inside all right so let me just start
off with a basic card so be card and
then close it and then
oh yeah second one so now I have two and
let's see let me start to put the
controls inside so actually I put volume
in the mock-up here but I have no idea
how to do the sound volume in the
browser so yeah I'll have to figure that
out power should be easy just make it
work or not work and then the sound name
should be easy so let me let's see so
let me do what do you call those things
switches switch style checkbox
yeah that looks okay I don't know why
it's so small oh that goes into other so
here are just the switches okay so I can
put a prop large I'm definitely gonna
put a prop large on that so it's just a
prop that denotes it as a switch so it's
a regular checkbox and then you pass it
a switch prop and it makes it a switch
okay so
oh cool and then it'll just give me the
label so I guess I'll put the label to
the right that's fine I'm not really
picky about that so a lot a large switch
and I'll call it the power switch so
let's see cool
so that switches on and off alright now
what was the next one Oh a slider for
volume so let me try to find a slider do
I call it a slider it's not a carousel I
mean it would be informed somewhere
maybe if I scroll does anyone know what
that's called
which is
all right maybe I mean view bootstrap
might just not have that so how else
would you control volume just up and
down I guess we could skip the volume
for now and then if we needed it we
could add in another library that has a
slider on it that wouldn't be a big deal
yeah it seems like it doesn't have it
unless it's in one of these other ones
rating is stars right yeah it's kind of
cool umm time picker input group
checkbox bar spare yeah I don't see one
here oh well oh is it called range Oh
range type input okay well they do have
one cool
all right this is the only example they
have Oh with different step values okay
yeah the basic one this is good so
basically it's a B form input and they
give it a type of range all right
okay I'll just put it after the power
and see how that looks
so ID range I don't even think I'll need
an ID here the model I'm gonna have to
set up the V models min max that's fine
okay so let me see all right that looks
okay I wonder now should I put the
volume I guess I could put the volume
yeah make it a lot smaller and put it
next to sound cuz you really don't need
the whole width for volume unless I put
volume at the bottom and put power and
the sound title here and then put volume
below it let's see also if I pass in if
I pass something into the form input
component that probably won't be a label
yeah cuz it's not like a check box so
let me try to I'll make that
self-closing and maybe I can pass in a
label which is volume okay
nope doesn't take label so it doesn't
have a list of props here no range
inputs return their value as a string
you may need to convert the value yeah
does not include styling for range
inputs inside input groups however
bootstrap you includes custom styling to
handle these situations until styling is
included in bootstrap
okay so bootstrap five just came out so
I'm guessing bootstrap five has styling
for this I mean I think maybe it's still
in alpha I'm not sure anyway let me add
the box here to show the name first and
then I'll figure out what I'm gonna do
with the volume where I'm gonna put it I
guess I saw a library on github view
bootstrap slider yeah I thought some
people called it slider I feel like I've
used it as a slider before or maybe it's
like the whole dialog modal thing
everyone's starting to call it a dialog
when we seem to be losing the name modal
to standardize it okay beef form input
and then I guess so I guess I'll be
putting rows and columns inside of this
card so if I do B row here and close the
B row and then let me put a checkbox or
not a checkbox let me put the name box
inside this row and then let's see also
this is this is quite zoomed in I mean
if i zoom out a little bit it's more
accurate so let me put I don't know a
div do they have paper I'm not sure if
they have
paper so what do I do if I want this
with like a just a regular box like an
outlined box without using another card
element so in beautiful I have something
called paper and I'm not sure I guess I
can just style it myself that might be
the easiest thing to do
okay I'm just going to style it just
make a box a regular div and I'm gonna
call it class equals main box search for
border so border are the classes they
have right reporters sidebar styling
borders border border yeah these are
utility classes for borders so border
right border danger those ones okay so I
can still make my own div here and might
not have to do a custom class because
then I can just use their utility
classes for spacing too
[Music]
so what is this let me let me just put a
placeholder here sound name and here
let's see let me get out of components
so where are their utility classes I
searched boost chip for utility classes
okay so this shows these are utility
classes from for spacing inside the
layout grid system okay so where would
the maybe these utility classes you have
border utilities okay it takes me to the
actual bootstrap so okay so I guess I
just use the these classes from
bootstrap so I can do border and then I
don't think I want border danger or
anything okay cool I gave me a border
and now I can add some margin or padding
classes so let me do padding all now let
me do padding let's see on the x-axis of
for bootstrap has a funky way of
calculating padding and margin that
isn't just multiplying so I think four
is something like 16 pixels are close to
it maybe and then this should be
something around six or eight pixels
okay I think that looks pretty good for
a box but it's not at all aligned here
so what I could do is add some I guess
CSS learn or what do I call that flexbox
classes inside the row
so let me see let me add a class of and
actually this row I don't know if the
rows default to display flex already let
me see you look inside row yeah it's
already defaulting to display flex yeah
thanks so I don't need to put display
flex in here so I can I think I can just
use flex elements now so I could do what
is it justify justify content oh it's
giving me all of them cool justify
content space between is the one I want
so let me start typing justify content
space between and oh it gave me an
underscore did he start with underscores
why did I do that I don't know if I did
that okay so it said the row already has
display flex but maybe it doesn't let me
try if that makes a difference no so let
me get rid of that okay so does anyone
know why this isn't pushing let me look
in the dev tools and see okay so in the
div okay so here
display flex flex wrap
and it's not justified content so the
class isn't corrected then so let me go
into the bootstrap flex classes I guess
this would be in the utility classes as
well so let me look in regular bootstrap
for flex utilities so or is it justified
content there and justified content okay
so it's just justify content between so
oh I put space between okay sweet okay
that works alright that's pretty good
now I do want to add some margin to the
row just in general and also to the card
because it's pushed up against
everything else so I'm gonna add some oh
wait I think I have to put it inside a
class so margin all or margin top of
[Music]
four let's see okay that's good that
pushes the top card down and let's see
I'd also want a margin I guess I for
each card I'll just add a margin top
margin top class equals margin top of
four okay that looks pretty good and I
don't want these to be so close to the
edges so let me add a margin let's see I
guess to the row here so I can add a
mark
more margin on the x-axis of to okay
that looks much better
all right so I have the sound name of
the power bar and then I like volume
being below that was too many things
squished into one row but I need some
kind of a title for it let me put it in
its own row first so it matches the rest
of the content so B row B row okay and
now I have the input so I guess I will
want an ID actually if I'm gonna give it
a label so the ID will just be volume I
guess oops
volume and then label for volume okay
and then
yeah just volume inside the label
alright and then I wanted to give this
the same kind of margin spacing that I
gave to the top row so I'll add class
equals M X of 2 and then I want some
margin top between the top row as well
so let me see how that looks
actually I want more margin between the
top row okay cool I think that looks
pretty good what do you think and yeah
and now I need the buttons in the bottom
card so let me see B row B card okay so
in this card I want to do did I get rid
of my class here I thought I had a class
of margin I guess I got rid of it at
some point margin top of 4 and now I
want to have basically square boxes that
are displayed I'm gonna be looping
through them too so I'm gonna want some
kind of flex wrap so that I can loop
through them all so let's see yeah
thanks
so it's basically like the first hour
trying to get the styling setup in the
second hour actually doing the Vijay s
work okay so let me just I guess just
create squares right there's no like
actual square class somewhere eventually
it would be cool to have one icon in
each button but
should they be buttons
I guess they should be buttons even
though they're square not rectangle I
think it would make sense so I'm
guessing it's be BTN maybe let's see
where are the buttons it's been a while
since I used bootstrap I think it has I
don't remember the last time I did oh by
the way one thing I found the other day
someone sent me I think is boots watch
it was they have all these free themes
for bootstrap and there are also
components and other things which I
thought was pretty cool that you can
just use any of these things and make
bootstrap look a lot nicer yeah maybe if
I make this drum app look nice I might
use one all right so here's a button
okay so it's spelled out B button and
then I can give it a variant if I want
I'll probably have outlined buttons
maybe so it's B button and then let me
just close it for now and then I'll put
sound or X or I don't know let's see
let's see how that looks okay okay
that's actually square so what kind of
square anyway now let me make that
bigger maybe if I just add enough
padding that will come out to be a big
square button so class equals although
if I had a div I would just set the size
of it instead of the padding so padding
all before
does it like that today yeah I gave it
the correct padding you know what I
don't think button is the is the right
thing for this I think I'm gonna use it
div div and then I'll just put an X
inside because that way it's not
dependent on what's inside of it for
spacing versus just padding a button so
let me do class equals patty
I guess I'm padding this too I'm gonna
just set the side it's the size of these
so let's do class
sound sound button I don't know okay
so sound button and now in my style tag
I can style sound button and padding all
okay good stir up dust P for all right
thanks so I'm gonna do width of 50
pixels height is 50 pixels because I
want to set absolute Heights and widths
on these okay so I can tell it got
bigger just by what is it yeah now it's
50 by 50 so this is actually gonna have
to be like 200 by 250 is not very big
200 pixels what did I get rid of pixels
okay so 200 by 200 and then I'm gonna
need to make the parent here so
this should already be oh no this is
inside a card so what I'm gonna do now
is do a biro because I want to wrap all
the buttons so I can loop through them
and then I think biro has not just flex
display flex it but I think it has flex
that row wrap so it'll just wrap the
containers around alright so inside of
the row and now I'll do I'm still gonna
want
I guess justify content center
okay and then let me start looping
through something here to display these
buttons so let me import clips into this
file so let me import because I'm
exporting this array of objects from
clips so it's not JSON or anything so I
can just import that array so clips from
clips and then let's see clips let me
put it on data here so let's make a data
function turn the object and do the
clips array so now there should be nine
clips in that file if I counted
correctly so now I can inside this sound
button I can let me put it on a few rows
I can do V 4 equals clip in clips and
then the key I'm just gonna use flip dot
name which all of them are unique so
because I already know that cool so it's
a little bit off but it's displaying
nine of them let me make these a little
bit smaller so let me try 160
one-sixty okay I think that's okay if I
Center them and and spread them out a
little bit and now let me add a border
so I can actually see where they are so
class I'm gonna add a border here cool I
think that's actually pretty good
I don't like that I can't scroll down
past this let me just
instead of margin just top I'm gonna
replace that with the y-axis so now I
can scroll down a little bit past the
bottom okay
so let's see what do I want to do these
should be a little bit spaced and the X
needs to be centered vertically and
horizontally which I can do with flexbox
and let me space these out just a little
bit so on the cards I can do margin of
one okay
all right that looks good and now for
the border actually let me do a border
of what can I do any color fuchsia does
that work no I think it has to be one of
those standard colors like warning or
something yeah and now the border
changed okay I'm gonna leave it like
that
I think it looks pretty good
oh yeah one more thing is that the
border that these cards have a border
radius but the things that I built do
not so let me see what the border radius
on these are border
mm-my on the right one let's see
computed yeah it should be here border
left border yeah here it is for pixels
okay so border top left side them
individually okay so I want these cards
to have four pixel radius because it
seems like everything else does and I'll
put it here too
so I think they have a utility class for
border radiuses let's see here we go
rounded okay and border classes so I
guess rounded would be
I don't feel like these sizes should be
standard and they don't say what the
sizes are anywhere let me see what this
actually means so I look at oh that's an
SVG will that's show me
oh that's 3.2 pixels and what's this one
okay so oh well I mean it's close enough
I'll get a little bit of a round so let
me do rounded large okay that's fine
rounded large it's close enough to four
for me anyway and let me put that class
here too oh let me put it next to the
other border class all right okay I
think that looks good it seems to match
up enough anyway okay so now I have all
the buttons let me just do one more
styling thing which is move this X to
Center it here and how do I do that
let's see I already have so many classes
here it's just so many classes so I'm
just gonna put them inside of here then
let me put so display flex oh wait I
can't do that down here display flex
align let me do justify first so justify
con content center align can I do a line
item center let's see okay cool
awesome and now I have everything
centered so even if I type text in there
like instead of the X I could do
let's say clip oh wait let me put this
in the double curly braces so clip dot
name I could put the name of the clip in
there oh cool I think that's actually
better for right now because there's no
icon associated with the clip so to have
the name of it you can tell these aren't
drums or anything although I do have a
drum set at my house I was thinking
about recording myself do it but I'd
have to move my whole audio setup into
another room to record each sound and I
just said okay well I'm just gonna use
these free mp3 files oh one more thing
one more thing I do want to style so on
hover
oops hover I do want to style let's see
was it out of the mouse pointer so
cursor is a pointer cursor or
cursor:pointer
I think it's cursor:pointer yeah and now
I have it looks like it's clickable cool
so it's not perfect styling but it's
okay I think okay thanks yeah I can't I
can't remember and CSS is is just a
memorization language kind of so it's
like if you're not in it every day it's
like you forget the exact terms you have
to use I guess so what do I want to do
next so I have I have all the clips
let's try to play sounds right so let's
let's make a function method here so
methods
oh no I hope you can hear the sounds
oh wait I think I have system audio
muted but maybe I can make it so you can
hear well let me get the sounds playing
first and see if you can hear them so
let's see play clip so this function
it's gonna have to take in the name of
the sound that URL so I'm gonna have to
pass in the exact clip and then this is
where I'm planning on using the was it
JavaScript the audio constructor so
audio not the html5 audio tag but the
well this this should come up somewhere
new audio yeah this is it not a lot of
details here all right yeah so basically
I can create new audio element and play
sounds in the browser that's yeah that's
as much as I can say about that I
thought it would show like oh yeah here
so once you create that audio element
you can do dot play and yeah there are
other things called like pause dot pause
I I should really contribute to that
documentation with some examples all
right so that's that's what I'm gonna be
using and I think that I can pass these
in dynamically which I hope is gonna
work so let's do let's let s equal new
audio so use the JavaScript constructor
and then I'll pass it in the clip which
actually let me call it clip URL so
there's no confusion about what I'm
passing in not the whole object I'm just
passing in the URL and then s is now
this audio object so now I should be
able to do as stop play all right so no
pause feature anything yet but that's
okay so I guess to do pause I'd have to
put it on data and do some other things
I don't know to capture which clip is
playing so I could pause it so okay so
now when I click on this button I need
to have some kind of I guess I'll just
put in an act click to capture the click
event directly on that div for my square
buttons so at click
is oh yeah the method I just made play
clip and then pass in the clip URL so
let's see pass in the clip dot what did
I call that and clips I called it clip
so it's clip clip I'm gonna change this
real quick sorry one second
so clip replace it with URL okay
that is much better no it's just URL
okay so now I can do clip dot URL pass
that in to play clip and I'm gonna make
sure my volume is on yeah yes can you
hear that it says that system audio is
playing through my stream okay thanks
thanks for confirming that alright so
this plays the clip that feels good oh
yeah the sound name I need to be
capturing which sound is playing so that
I can update the sound name cool hi
Bruce how are you let's see I guess yeah
I'll just have like current sound
current clip since I'm using the clip
terminology so let's say empty string at
first and then
or latest clip because it's not current
clip if it doesn't change after the clip
ends so our last played last played I
don't know that's fine so let me do so
I'll do this dot last played equals okay
then in this case I can't just pass in
the clip URL I'm gonna have to pass in
the whole clip so I'll have to pass in
the name and the URL and then here I'll
update this to URL and then last played
will be set to the name okay so now I
have to update that here so oops
oh wait wait here I'll just pass in the
whole clip and then I'm pulling URL a
name off of that and what's the other
thing
oh yeah the sound name so I'm gonna have
to put last played here oh that kind of
stinks cuz when it's empty it turns into
the shriveled thing I'm gonna have to
put a default sound okay yeah I'm gonna
have to put some a default there no
sound or something so it doesn't just
fold okay cool alright so let me hook up
the power switch then and see so what
should I do for the power switch
I guess that the
easiest thing to do would be to put
something on data like a boolean on or
off and then have an if statement inside
play clip but what I should actually do
is make these disabled so you can't
click on them or show that they're
disabled like grade them out somehow so
I could do a class okay let me first let
me V model the checkbox here so put this
on two lines so the pack that power
switch
let me remodel that so I can capture the
value equals power should I do is power
nope because power can mean different
things so is on I know that JavaScript I
should do camel case so is on so in data
now I'll do is on oh let me start off
with true and then you can turn it off
if you want okay cool so it's definitely
mapping now because it starts off is
true and then it goes off alright so now
I have to disable these buttons which
I'm going to do through an if statement
unless someone else has a better idea so
and then I can add a class to the
buttons to kind of show the user that
they're disabled since they're not
actual buttons they're divs
so I'll just change the class or
something
oh yeah instead of sound button maybe
I'll have disabled button or something
I don't know okay so if this dot is on
then I can do all that stuff all right
but now Soph
doesn't do anything sweet but now I
don't want these classes so I want to
grade them out somehow so I don't know
should what should I do an overlay or
something let me make a new class here
so let's call this button this say bold
and say now let's change the border
color I guess border now will be gray so
okay so now if it's off oh I'm not
actually applying the class yeah okay so
button disabled now I have to
conditionally toggle the class so let's
see how do I want to do this so because
there's a bunch of classes here so let
me see uh so I can do object syntax or
array syntax and if I want to toggle
so I think let me look this up so view
Jay s dynamic classes and
[Music]
yeah I think if I do object syntax I can
put the rest of the classes after the
object right and then I don't have to
put them all inside the object so I
could just have no I don't think I can
do that so I think maybe I need an array
here then so maybe I need an object
inside of an array let's see and then
this would be inside of a string and
then inside the object it would be so
I'd be checking is is on and then if it
is on that I want my class button
disabled so I'm gonna have to put that
in quotes so button disabled so it
doesn't like this so I think I need a
comma here maybe oh yeah it seems to do
okay with that that's good so if is on
oh if not is on its meaning if it's not
on then the button is disabled okay let
me try that doesn't like it okay let me
see what's going on with the buttons so
okay now okay so it is adding the class
properly because it's it's changing and
now it's adding button disabled to all
the buttons but my problem is now in my
CSS so do i do border color but border
let's see now I think because it's
putting that class first that's why so I
would have to put this class at the end
basically let me do this on two lines so
I would have to put this class at the
end so actually I'm gonna get this out
and paste it after oh yeah then put that
back okay so now it should work no it
doesn't work it doesn't like that let's
see why is it changing the border color
though so I have button disabled here
and it's called button disabled here and
that's good it might still be putting
the class at the beginning
okay so border bottom color border left
color I mean for this small app I could
just do an important statement because
it's not overriding it so I'm wondering
if that's what bootstrap has let me look
at the rules yeah
that's what they're doing they're doing
border color important so to overwrite
they're important I'm gonna have to use
another important statement because
that's how important work everything is
more important all right so that's fine
whatever
okay that's good and now if it's on it
goes orange and if it's off it goes yeah
that's what I have right now I don't
know maybe you said that a long time ago
though without the sound button I don't
know how long the leg is right now
hopefully it's not too long but
sometimes on YouTube it can get a bit
long yeah this is the same thing I had
maybe it wasn't when you said that
comment though oh I guess it's not
because it's not is on but yeah the
important did it because bootstrap is
using important statements but I want to
look at it I want to make it look like
more disabled than it is you know cuz
this looks like it still could be a
button oh also the pointer the pointer
needs to go away I should do in
either-or class really except I want
some of these things like actually I
want all of these things except the
Huffer so oh you know what I could do
though is border warning what if I put
this inside here too so that way I don't
need the border gray right let me see
let me take out the board of gray and
see because that way if it's not on oh
now it's opposite
oh right okay
well I'll never mind because I forgot
I'm doing it if it's not on display of
these classes okay so that was a bad
idea
let me go back I could do another so I
could I guess I could do a turnery here
like is on and I don't know would that
be inside a nested like let me see if I
can do a turnery here and do so here I
would have to do I would have to do is
on yeah I could do two objects that
would definitely work I'm gonna try to
do this so let me get rid of that and
then I can do so if it's on oh no no no
I don't want the button to be disabled
let's see I want water
warning oh wait and then if it's not on
I want the other one I think this is
gonna work and that way I don't have to
do two objects inside I can just check
is on once it's not giving me an error
so I think it will work
yeah that works cool awesome
so let me now change I don't know should
I add an overlay I could add a
background just to make it look more
disabled like background color of light
gray then we turn it off
I don't know and then get rid of the
mouse actually you know there's one
pointer there's one mouse pointer that
has like an X let me look that up cuz
cursor Mouse pointers CSS
help wait crosshair cursor crosshair or
cursor not allowed let me see let me see
which one which one would look better so
now let me go to hover so and hover and
then cursor which which one should I try
across here across here oh no that's not
what I want I thought this was something
different that's not at all that looks
like I can drag and select what about
not allowed
yeah not allowed this one I don't know
if you can see it it has the little
circle with a line through it in it okay
so I'm gonna do not allowed not allowed
okay cool
now it really looks disabled like you
can't do anything and now if I put the
power back you can click on okay that
all works now so what should i do i
guess i should do volume i actually have
no idea how to do this I don't think
I've ever done volume in the browser
let's see
so JavaScript audio what the audio
constructor volume
hmm
audio context I wonder if it's audio
context
okay this probably doesn't say anything
yeah so that doesn't say anything let me
look at audio context real quick
interface represents an audio processing
graph built from audio no I don't think
that's what I want
create gain create is that what I want I
really have no idea I could just look
straight up like how to set volume in
JavaScript let's see if this is what
they're doing okay this person is trying
to play and mix multiple sounds play the
same sounds interrupt playback let me
see if they have volume okay so this was
in 2012 the Web Audio API is now
supported although there are a lot of
issues no common volume controls let me
see the link that it provides so it goes
to the github page okay Web Audio API
editors draft so this is the absolute
latest from 2020
an audio pram interface for controlling
an individual aspect of an audio notes
functioning such as volume oh you said
document that my audio oh I can change
it audio volume so I could do it here
then right so let's see I could do s dot
volume equals to or point two point two
and close this then alright yeah that
does work
cool thanks umm yeah so I guess yeah let
me do it to equal this dot range and
then I'm gonna have to give it a default
here so let's say actually mid max so
range has a min Max where is range here
it is so min zero max five and the model
of value let me change the value to
range or no no let me change it to
volume okay so volume and then I'll put
it here so this will be volume and let
me start it off at two so in the middle
and then here it will be volume cool
thank you thanks for that
nope oh wait I think this does this have
to be a zero to one number I think it
might have to be let me look at whatever
you w3schools
yeah that's what I thought Thanks zero
to one okay so the light can't be too
bad because that seemed to your comment
seem to come up pretty quick dumb audio
volume property yeah so this is the same
thing that volume alright let's see so I
guess I'll divide it by if it's zero to
five man I can't even think right now so
let me divide it by five oh wait right
and stuff volume divided by five and it
should be zero to one so by ten oh cool
that works that works really well thanks
I divided it by five because my max here
is five so it's one two five zero is off
anyway because you're gonna have zero
divided by five so it's zero so it won't
play any sound okay well I didn't even
know how to do volume before today so
that's off this on yeah it's not a huge
difference but there's a difference
thank you thanks for all your help so is
there anything else I should do let's
see it's been an hour and 37 minutes
sounds like 20 more minutes left um what
else could you do with a drum machine I
guess get actual drum sounds but this
was one thing that I didn't realize
because I guess I thought it'd have to
use the audio tag but it's cool that I
can just pass in a URL dynamically to
the audio constructor and it just plays
that's pretty cool I think this is a
nice API Oh what if what if we try to
set up the pause I think that's gonna be
a lot harder so pause I think this
should actually be stop stop right not
pause because I'm not really pausing I'm
stopping so
[Music]
let's see so I'd need I would need this
instance of audio I think I need this
stored on data so that I can run stop on
it basically because then I could do
this dot current clip no no no like this
dot audio current audio audio maybe cuz
that's the audio object and then I could
do dot stop run dot stop or is it dot
pause is that there should be a dot stop
right but the only one I know for sure
is that pause so let's let me see if
this works so I would do current audio
which at first would just be an empty
object and what else
so oh yeah so I need to actually do that
here so then this would be this dot
current audio and then I would do yeah
basically here oh no I would set this
after so let me do I don't like using
s-pen I guess I could change it to a and
then this dot current audio equals a and
then I could stop it here basically oh
but if I'm just pausing it's going to
pause in the middle of the clip then I
need to reset it
right reset it back to the beginning of
the clip let me just see let me see how
this works
a is not defined oh oh right
so actually I'm not redefining it here
so let me do Const okay oh yeah I need a
stop button how do I stop should I just
do a pause button in the middle here I
could change it into a pause button
until it's done playing and then change
it back into the name I think that would
be pretty cool let me add a pause button
here just so I can test this out real
quick up at the top
so in between power and last played let
me add B button and I guess the variant
is it call variant could be I don't know
info so it's a different color and then
what do I want to say oh yeah pause or
stop stop
okay stop cool and now I can add an act
clique to this so at click click equals
oh yeah stop
it's just stopped that's my method name
so let me try this no it's it's not fast
enough because all these clips are like
one second long it's I think it I think
it did stop
yeah it did okay so stop works and I it
didn't sound like I had to reset it do I
have to reset it back to zero let me try
to stop the band or yeah it does stop
and then it does start over again
so I guess pause just started the clip
over I don't know if that's the intended
behavior but that's what it seems to be
doing okay so that seems to work now my
cats meowing for attention let me
actually because everything else is
outlined let me outline that button it
looks like a eyesore in the middle of
everything or I wonder if I should just
put stop no because then I would have to
no I would have to time when the clip
stopped and then change it back to the
name I don't have time for all that
because I don't think I have time to
figure out how to do that but that would
be an interesting thing if I could do
that let me just fix the button for
right now let me fix oh I can just do
outline - so let me do outline - then
info so outline - info okay that looks a
bit better yeah and this looks clickable
this looks like it's not clickable so
that's good
there should be a resume if you want to
resume I'm not sure saving the current
like is it saving the current state so
when I stop is it saving that because I
guess play starts over at zero thanks
way funnier I could actually make music
like this oh there should be a repeat
like I should be able to toggle these on
repeat so you can actually make a song
I wonder how to do that so let's see
also right now stop if I'm doing
multiple things that just stopped the
last one not like every single sound
what do you mean no
no you don't like the random sounds or
no it's not music or I don't know what
no means or you don't want repeat I
guess that's not really a drum machine
or yeah a drum machine you would have
repeat oh don't mix these sounds oh
don't don't mix them because if it
I have repeat then I'll have the horse
sound over and over again with poker
chips and everything yeah they're not
the best sounds to put together okay
well so some ideas were that I could do
resume on the sound but the sound starts
over
so I guess also I'm when I play it again
I'm setting this to a new current audio
so yeah I wonder if if there's a way to
know like when a clip finished how would
I know when a clip finishes because then
I could check to see if a clip finishes
and I could actually have a current
audio array and I could be watching the
array check when a clip finishes and
then take it out of the array I think
that would be the more advanced way to
do this let me actually see I know I'm
stuck on the repeat but let me see if
there's JavaScript sound no audio audio
repeat
oh you can do loop I have to try this I
have stopped so I'll be able to stop it
let me do loop here so do I do it
instead of play is that what I do let me
try a dot loop let me do something not
too bad no it doesn't play so I think I
need to do before play okay so I think I
need to okay let's try this here didn't
work
a dot loop is not a function so-oh
element do be this true okay all right
so it's the property so let's do dot
true and try this okay let me refresh
shoot turn it all the way up shoot cool
so I guess I could have a toggle that
says loop or not loop but the problem is
okay so what I'm gonna do now is
actually stop the currently playing
sound if there's a current sound I'm
going to call stop first before I set a
new audio and do all this stuff because
otherwise I'm not going to be able to
stop old sounds right now so I'm gonna
do that real quick so I'm gonna run this
dot stop first
oh wait that's a method so I'll run this
dot stop to make sure all of their audio
stops because otherwise multiple things
might be looping and then I can have a
loop toggle so let me do loop and I'll
set that to false and I can do a dot
loop here is this dot loop and then I'll
have a toggle up at the top and I think
this will be the last thing that I can
do in this stream so the power so okay
let me put this loop maybe I'll just put
it around the in the second row with the
volume and let me say loop
Luke Oh Luke and let me say it loop okay
so that's kind of messy something's
wrong here this stock current audio dot
pause is not a function oh because if if
the current audio is stopped already I
guess it removes itself or it's no
longer a callable method so I'm gonna
have to say what should I do so if this
dot no wait if this dot
where's it current current audio
wait I let me just do a try-catch here
that's probably the quickest thing to do
try and then catch
so I'll just log that the error not as
an error but just says that oh yeah I
need to close the catch all right so
yeah okay that's looping properly let me
stop didn't throw an error because it
was still playing that time so let me
turn loop off cool also looping does
work this is messy let me fix the mess
in the top real quick I wonder if that
should be below like I could do another
biro maybe if there are more options and
then I can add loops I can add looping
there of course in these other B rows
there are more styling options so maybe
I want to add those too hey I didn't get
the space in there okay okay that's
better
it's not really good looking but at
least it's not on top of each other
okay cool um yeah so I guess that's it
for the drum machine let me push my code
what I have from today so let me I'm
inside the drum app right now let me
just CD up one directory in case I have
changes from there and let's see get
status
oh yeah cuz I moved two clips yes so
good
I'll catch all those changes too so let
me do get add wait let me make sure I
did might get ignore properly first so I
have a good ignore yeah I just wanted to
make sure I had added my get ignore
first okay so that should handle all
that so I can do get status that will
add the view app and the drum machine so
do you get add just add everything get
commit - m co Oh
drum machine code from livestream on
July 3rd cool which is a holiday weekend
here in the US
Thank You Sachi it was nice having you
thanks for all the help so let me
refresh this here cool I think it was
more fun after I got the styling worked
out at the first 20 30 minutes but yeah
I'm gonna try to figure out why Inc line
wouldn't work after the stream alright
so here's all of the app the drum
machine some markdown previewer and
quote machine let's see and then next
week so next Friday I'll be doing the
next app which I actually don't know
what it is yet so let's see here's the
drum machine oh if I go in to learn
I can see all the front-end projects
front-end libraries
yeah so drum machine ok calculator oh I
actually built a calculator to five
years ago I built the calculator
actually for this project so I'm gonna
have to find my old code I definitely
did it in react and I think I've done
one in jQuery too so yeah we'll see I'll
probably be shocked at what my code
looked like back then
alright yeah javascript calculator and
then a Pomodoro clock I remember my
Pomodoro clock that was like it looks
kind of like a time machine really weird
UFO style so those two are coming in the
future and then after that I want to
build kind of a bigger project more of
the style that I do on my regular
Channel
yeah thanks tech stats thanks for
joining me in the chat it was nice
getting to chat with everyone this week
yeah if you are interested in VJ s like
view content I publish free videos and
livestreams on my Faraday Academy
channel if you want to check it out
thanks Bruce thanks for watching yeah I
hope you learned something from today
and feel free to leave me a comment
below or come over to my channel and you
can see how to contact me from there so
have a great day everybody
take care